hello teachers i'm sal khan founder of
the not-for-profit khan academy with the
goal of helping you accelerate outcomes
in your classroom and i have an exciting
announcement what we are launching is a
new mastery framework on khan academy we
have some of the most significant
features ever around personalization and
mastery learning where your students can
get as much practice as they need as
much feedback as they need and the most
important part of a mastery learning
system is the teacher is the human being
in the classroom so it's explicitly
designed to increase human interactions
to give you the teacher insights on
which students might need help which
students might need a little bit of
motivation we've designed dashboards so
that teachers can identify gaps and
misconceptions in their students in real
time we've significantly added to the
amount of content not just in math where
we've always had tens of thousands of
exercises from kindergarten through
calculus and statistics but also in high
school and college level sciences and
the humanities and most importantly it's
flexible to meet your needs this can be
done in the classroom it could be used
as part of in class practice it could be
part of review or it can be done as part
of homework and we are seeing that
classrooms that use khan academy for the
classroom at least 30 minutes per week
are seeing incredible gains in their
student outcomes
i look at my reports a lot i use data a
lot to drive my instruction and to drive
what i need to reteach it tell me
exactly where that student is it tells
me how many attempts have they have done
it specifically so there's real data
telling me hey the student is getting it
wrong they're not doing 30 problems and
then realizing uh i don't know what i'm
doing and i just made some really bad
habits for myself so thank you teachers
all of us at khan academy are incredibly
inspired by the work that you do day in
and day out anything we can do to make
your lives easier or to help accelerate
the learning for your students we are
excited to do with you
[Music]